an was denkst du wenn ich Japan sage
vielleicht Gaming unheimlich gutes Essen
Kultur oder Mister Nippon und was wenn
ich dir sage dass man all das und noch
viel mehr mit 100 Euro in der größten
Stadt der Welt in 24 Stunden erleben
kann viel Spaß mit 100 Euro
14.000 Yen in Tokio ja
[Musik]
als allererstes braucht mir aber die
Kohle 100 € sind 14.000 Yen und die
geben uns jetzt ab damit wir uns einen
schönen Tag machen können
[Musik]
es ist so krank das hier sind 14.000 Yen
und ziemlich genau 100 € und von diesem
Geld muss ich heute Verpflegung
Unterkunft Freizeitaktivitäten und
Transportmittel bezahlen und genau damit
fangen wir jetzt an U-Bahn ist die
Möglichkeit hier in Tokio und
wahrscheinlich überall in Japan
600 Yen 24 Stunden unlimited rights kann
man gar nicht sagen vor allem weil Tokio
eins der besten öffentlichen
Verkehrssysteme der gesamten Welt das
braucht es aber auch den Tokio ist mit
39 Millionen Einwohnern die größte Stadt
der Welt und so ziemlich jeder der dort
lebt benutzt dieses System um von A nach
B zu kommen also Bus Bahn und so weiter
bevor wir von dieser Karte aber jetzt
Gebrauch machen erstmal zum Frühstück an
hauptverkehrspunkten und ihrem Bahnhöfen
geht nämlich nicht nur Bahn gefahren
sondern auch gelegt es gibt
Einkaufsmöglichkeiten Klamotten
Geschäfte Klamottengeschäfte und eine
Menge Restaurants und Plätze an denen
man richtig gut im Bahnhof essen kann
also die Bahnstation oder Bahnhöfe sind
hier gar nicht als solche zu erkennen
zumindest für uns Deutsche nicht es ist
riesengroß wirkt viel mehr wie ein
Einkaufszentrum und genau deswegen
frühstücken wir heute auch hier in der
Bahnstation
[Musik]
Grüntee aufs Haus und so ein warmes
Handtuch um die Hände sauber zu machen
gibt es in allen Restaurants aber dass
das auch im Bahnhof so ist und dass man
im Bahnhof frisch bekocht wird also wir
offene Küche wir gucken in Köchen hierzu
beim Kochen super schicker Laden
wahrscheinlich ist jetzt nicht das äh
traditionellste sich in Bahnhof zu
setzen und zu essen aber das geht eben
hier also ist super einfach es geht mega
schnell und von hier aus können wir dann
quasi in den Tag starten und überall in
Tokyo hin unser Essen ist da Fleisch ein
Ei auf Reis ziemlich einfaches Gericht
zum Hauptgericht kommt noch nie so Suppe
wir bezahlen unter 10 € mega geil und
auf möglich und so macht halt sowas
[Musik]
Herdecke 1000 1280 Yen pro Hauptgericht
inklusive nie so Suppe als Vorspeise
Grüntee der die ganze Zeit nach
geschenkt wurde und bei all diesen
ganzen Ausgaben fragt ihr euch mit recht
wie ich das alles im Überblick behalte
die Antwort ist ganz einfach finanzguru
der Partner des heutigen Videos die App
ist ein digitaler finanzassistent der
all eure Einnahmen und Ausgaben über
verschiedene Konten verteilt trackt das
ganze ist komplett kostenlos und ihr
könnt alle eure verschiedenen Konten und
sogar Neo Broker wie scalable capital
mit in die App eintragen und habe
dadurch euer Depot mit in der
Finanzübersicht ihr seht was reinkommt
ihr seht was rausgeht und vor allem aber
wohin was rausgeht ihr seht alle eure
Verträge an einem Ort in der App
gebündelt und könnt diese dort direkt
recht sicher kündigen und bekommt ein
Sparpotenzial angezeigt also wie viel
bleibt am Ende des Monats real bei euch
übrig dass ihr für sparen für Urlaub
oder wofür auch immer benutzen könnt
vielleicht zeigt euer Konto 1000 € an
finanzguru weiß aber dass sie noch 500 €
Miete und 50 € für ein Handyvertrag
zahlen müsst das also genau noch 450
Euro übrig bleibt das ist unheimlich
wichtig allgemein für die Übersicht fürs
investieren für sparen oder wenn ihr
genau in so einem Urlaub nach Japan über
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
und mit dem Code Dave könnt ihr
finanzguru Plus für ganze 3 Monate
komplett kostenlos testen mit finanzguru
plus hast du zusätzlich zur
Grundversionen noch weitere Features wie
Analysen smarte Budget Vorschläge oder
das verfügbare Einkommen zur Verfügung
also ladet euch die App herunter
registriert euch verknüpft eure Konten
tragt den Code Dave unter dem Reiter
mehr ein und erlangt volle Übersicht
über eure Finanzen und jetzt auch noch
mal ein riesen Dankeschön an finanzguru
die es möglich machen dass wir so viel
Zeit und Arbeit in die Videos stecken um
euch das bestmögliche Ergebnis zu
liefern und damit jetzt weiter viel Spaß
der
lebensunterhaltungskostenindex gibt
Aussage darüber wie teuer oder günstig
leben in verschiedenen Städten ist dabei
werden Preise von ganz alltäglichen
Dingen wie Brot Wasser einer Taxifahrt
eine MAC Menü oder eben der Miete
verglichen New York ist dabei immer der
Master mit einem Wert von 100 auf Platz
11 gibt es also zehn Städte in denen ist
teurer es zu leben und eine Menge Städte
in denen es günstiger ist so eben auch
in Tokio Japan Tokio belegt mit 73,74
den 87 Platz im Index und sollte
deswegen im günstiger sein als New York
und das hat beim Frühstück immer
aufgestimmt aber wie sieht es bei
anderen Punkten unsere Bahn ist da wie
immer in Japan auf die Sekunde pünktlich
ein Traum
[Musik]
in Japan wird in der Bahn quasi nicht
gesprochen oder telefoniert einfach weil
viele Leute auf dem Weg zu arbeiten die
Zeit noch nutzen um zu schlafen und so
aber nicht nur in Bahnhöfen gibt es
einiges zu sehen und Möglichkeiten zu
shoppen sondern auch in Einkaufszentren
und zwar ein Einkaufszentren die in
keiner Weise mit dem zu vergleichen sind
was wir aus Deutschland kennen im
Prinzip riesige Konsum Tempel in denen
ist nicht viele kleine Läden gibt
sondern wo dieses gesamte Ding ein
riesen Laden ist
alles gamifight überall Mucke Sounds und
so weiter
ich bin etwas aufgeregt es könnte sogar
direkt eine neue Rolex Trader Folge
werden zumindest vor einigen Jahren
konnte man hier richtig gute Deals
machen und Kameras zu einem Bruchteil
des Preises kaufen unheimlich viele
Menschen an einem Platz Rolltreppen in
alle Richtungen Töne Werbung Lichter und
eben alles an Produkten was man sich
vorstellen kann von Füller über Gaming
Stühle zu Champagner Lebensmitteln
Outdoor Möbel einfach alles alles blinkt
leuchtet und es macht Kopfschmerzen
völliger Reizüberflutung kein Witz wir
waren eine Stunde drin am Kopfschmerzen
bekommen haben uns dann dafür
entschieden an den nächsten Platz zu
gehen an dem viel zu viele Menschen auf
einem Haufen sind chiboya crossing
Tokio ohne bei crossing vorbeizugehen
nicht nur sind wir in der größten Stadt
der Welt sondern die größte Kreuzung der
Welt bis zu 3000 Leuten können in einer
Ampelschaltung da drüber gehen und kein
Witz plötzlich habe ich mitten in der
Menschenmasse ein Homie von mir gesehen
in Tokio auf crossing und dann ziemlich
schnell gemerkt dass es gar nicht darum
ist aber das war auch gar nicht der den
wir in Tokyo treffen wollten sondern
dazu aber später im Video mehr und dann
sind wir tatsächlich über den
Zebrastreifen gelaufen ja man mag es
kaum glauben dann haben wir den Kaffee
im Starbucks getrunken direkt
mit der besten Aussicht
die es jemals bei irgendeinem Starbucks
gab der Zebrastreifen war super nicht
nur weil es ein Zebrastreifen ist
sondern weil es eine der
weltberühmtesten Sehenswürdigkeiten ist
und hätten wir den Kaffee nicht
getrunken er das auch komplett kostenlos
gewesen so langsam kam der Hunger aber
und das bedeutet es ist Zeit für einen
snapchat family Markt genau das gleiche
wie seven eleven und so weiter so ein
convenience store und hier gibt's
abgepacktes Essen hört sich erstmal
nicht so gut an ist aber tausendmal
besser als alles was man aus Deutschland
kennt Nudeln aller Art vegetarisch mit
Fleisch mit Fisch quasi frisch aber halt
so eingepackt und ist nicht so komplette
Müll wie man es aus Deutschland kennt
ich glaube ich nehme das hier 369 Yen
fürs Essen 150m für den Kaffee ziemlich
genau 4 € Hammer und damit komme ich mit
Sicherheit bis zum Abend essen das
dachte ich zumindest nachdem ich nämlich
das Essen ausgesucht habe und nichts
lieber wollte als es einfach nur zu
verspeisen ist mir eine Sache wieder
eingefallen irgendwie hat es sich schon
im Laden falsch angefühlt das mit
rauszunehmen und ich dachte so jetzt
esse ich das einfach gerade auf dem Weg
dahin und dann ist mir wieder
eingefallen ich habe ein Video von
Mister Nippon gesehen Link ist unten in
der Video Beschreibung in Japan wird im
Gehen und jetzt vor allem in so einer
Situation in so einer vollen Straße auf
keinen Fall gegessen und getrunken also
muss ich mich jetzt irgendwo in der Ecke
verziehen oder so mir das schnell
schnell rein sondern oder eben einen Ort
finden an dem es genehmigt ist zu essen
das ist mein 3 € Essen für vorne habe
ich den Euro Kaffee angerichtet
es würde sich niemand beschweren wenn
man das so im Restaurant bekommen würde
willst du wenn es eine Sache gibt die
mich in Tokyo wirklich nervt oder in
Japan allgemein es sind keine Mülleimer
auf offenen Straßen man muss sich übelst
die Finger rumsuchen bis man die Sachen
irgendwie wegschmeißen kann und trotzdem
ist ja alles kleben ich trinke jetzt
einfach in der Öffentlichkeit und das
alles nur um endlich gut gestärkt zocken
zu können
zu japanischen Kultur gehört Gaming und
damit auch spielehallen einfach dazu
sechs Stockwerke voll mit Arcade die
komplette Straße ist voll die komplette
Straße ist beleuchtet jetzt wird
bisschen Geld verzockt das restliche
Geld
[Musik]
wir sollten lieber irgendwas spielen wo
wir durch das Spielen schon gewonnen
haben und nicht uns durch den Gewinn
erst besser fühlen und dafür gehen wir
in Stockwerk hoch ich würde sofort hier
auf der Ebene irgendwas zocken ihr hört
das schon deutlich lauter die Leute sind
am Trommeln Mama alle Games am zocken
aber ich schwöre auf dieser Ebene ist
jeder Automat belegt hier ist alles
belegt wir gehen weiter hoch aber hier
geht's jetzt für uns Casual Gamer weiter
aber als erstes hole ich mir was zu
trinken überall in Japan und den Tokio
stehen diese vending machine
[Musik]
900 Yen für zwei Stunden Spaß und das
war ein Traum 500 Yen für den Greifarm
hätte man sich sparen können die 400 Yen
die wir danach fürs Rennspiel ausgegeben
haben waren deutlich besser investiert
aber all in all war das ein absolutes
Erlebnis und ich würde sofort wieder hin
nicht nur zum selber spielen sondern
auch von den Leuten zuzugucken die
scheinbar etwas mehr Zeit dort
verbringen denn das war fast noch
beeindruckender als selber zu spielen um
dann irgendwie damit klar zu kommen kein
Hauptgewinn mit nach Hause zu nehmen
gibt es eine Lösung und das ist Frust
Essen
so jetzt tiktok Empfehlung mit Dave hier
so eine kleine Gasse sind rechts und
links überall kleine Shots zum Essen und
genau hier werden wir jetzt zu Abend
essen
für 1.800 Yen in dieser Straße quasi vor
den Augen bekocht zu werden war schon
wirklich was besonderes dazu noch zwei
Bier auch alles im Preis mit inbegriffen
das war wirklich ein Erlebnis also die
Straße sah gut aus man hat so eine Art
Tapas gegessen konnte sich viel
rumprobieren und äh es hat sich
irgendwie authentisch angefühlt auch
wenn es das vielleicht nicht ganz ist
weil schon viele Touristen unterwegs
waren Preise auch dementsprechend waren
und man so ein bisschen das Gefühl hatte
die Ladenbesitzer machen Druck man wurde
angehalten etwas mehr zu bestellen etwas
schneller zu essen und wenn man die
Rechnung bestellt hat ging es auch
relativ schnell weil die nächsten Gäste
schon auf einen Platz gewartet haben man
merkt leider schon ist ein bisschen
touristisch aber es ist auch einfach
unglaublich nice die Straße unglaublich
nice die Läden und super geile Erfahrung
wahrscheinlich sogar mein Favorit bis
dahin Tokio ja genau zurück an 100 € in
New York da konnte ich für 99 $ gerade
mal in einem fünf Personen Schlafsaal
pennen hat das deswegen damals nicht
gemacht weil ich sonst gar kein Budget
mehr gehabt hätte und hat bei Leuten aus
der Community gepennt jetzt ist es hier
so dass wir für 35 € und ein eigen
Wohnzimmer haben in der größten Stadt
der Welt 38 Millionen Leute wohnen in
Tokio das ist richtig krank das Zimmer
ist zwar klein aber wir haben eigenes
Zimmer und das gucken uns jetzt mal an
das ganze ist und vielleicht konntet ihr
es euch schon denken ein kapselhotel und
für diese 35 € pro Nacht haben wir jeder
unsere eigene Kapsel ein Schließfach und
ein ziemlich sauberes gemeinschaftspark
bekommen auch hier in der Dusche alles
super klein aber eben auch für kleines
Geld bisschen Organisation dann
funktioniert das schon 10 Uhr Checker
time äh deswegen ist hier jetzt niemand
mehr wir können euch die Pots zeigen
zwei zweieinhalb Quadratmeter man hat
USB Steckplätze kann lauter und leiser
drehen damit man die Ansagen von unten
mitbekommen so jetzt check out time wir
können die nicht komplett zu machen es
gibt quasi nur so ein Blind dass man
runterziehen kann deswegen wird er
eigentlich nicht geredet und das war's
besonders bequem ist es nicht besonders
erholsamen Schlaf hatte ich auch nicht
aber was erwartet man für diesen Preis
in so einer Metropole also wenn ihr
günstig nach Tokio Reisen wollt dann ist
das vermutlich die beste Option und
bevor wir jetzt aber von der Kapsel
Gebrauch machen erstmal noch zu einem
Treffen mit einer ganz besonderen Person
zum Tagesabschluss
was zu viel bedeutet wie frei sucht
zumindest auf begrenzte Zeit hier in so
einem geilen Laden wie auch da wo wir
gerade eben zu Abend gegessen haben ganz
viele kleine Spots nebeneinander
gemeinsam mit Mister Nippon was geht ab
wenn ihr mehr davon sehen wollt schaut
auf dem zweitkanal vorbei da gibt es
eine Block Playlist wunderbar 2 Stunden
all you can drink für 2000 Yen was
meiner Meinung nach nicht nur ziemlich
günstig sondern auch ein gebürtige
Abschluss für diese 24 Stunden in Japan
Tokios sind somit haben wir
13.914 Yen insgesamt in dieser Zeit
ausgegeben und damit unser 100 € Budget
fast komplett ausgereizt kommen wir nun
aber zum wie sehr lohnt sich eine Reise
Ranking und das hier wird ziemlich
interessant Anreise zwei von fünf weil
langer und teurer Flug Location 5 und 5
super viel zu sehen Tokio war mega nice
super sauber einfach Allround eine super
experience fun factor 4 von 5 es gibt
eine Menge zu tun gutes Essen fun fun
fun fun 455 wohlfühl Faktor 55 es ist
unglaublich die Stadt ist obwohl sie so
riesig ist unheimlich leise niemand
spricht in der Bahn alles ist sauber
Wohlfühlfaktor ist in Japan wirklich
richtig krass habe ich noch nie vorher
so erlebt und noch mal hinfaktor 55 wir
haben unheimlich viel gesehen aber nicht
im Ansatz alles gesehen ich möchte
unbedingt noch mal hin Japan hat mich in
seinen Bann gezogen und es war eine
hammer experience so eine gute
experience sogar das Japan mit 24 von 30
Punkten im wie sehr lohnt sich eine
Reise Ranking auf Platz 1 an New York
vorbei ziehen wenn euch das Video
gefallen hat lass mir ein Like da
vergessen den Kanal abonnieren und dann
sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder
tschüss
[Musik]